Sẽ mấy kéo trở mà của n vải, chảy vào công việc ở thành phố Binh Cát,
mất nờ lật khiến hàng đề chết nằm bảo vệ đang đứng ở cầu.
Ông mai công, năm mỗi tuổi, cuối khoảng năm 2018, công ty sẽ sất bặt trên phụ,
đám tại khu công nghiệp Mỹ phút bà, thành phố Binh Cát đứng trước cộng mô mì chiến thảm à.
Lúc này, Sẽ mấy kéo trẻ từ ngoài đường vào công vối tốt độ nhàng bất nờ bị lật.
Bà của hành bằng vài nhựa phía sau xây rất xún đất, đẹp nằm bảo vệ vào tường.
Nhưng người cố gắng đứng kiện hàng dày kiểu nạn như không thành công.
Sở đó, công nhân đưa xe năng bị cầu bà của n với lên đưa nạn nhân dọ ngoài đi cấp cứu,
sau người này không có khỏi.
Nghe 258, công hăng bình dưỡng đã mời tài xí xe mấy kéo cùng một số nhân chứng để làm só vụ việc.